so my name is attend a nap and I'm
working at Wolfram in the domain of
machine learning and so I will present
you today the function we worked on for
roughly the past two years and and then
I will tell you a bit about what we are
currently working on and and also what's
our project for for longer longer term
and so I think it's a good occasion that
you know you you know ask questions and
give your comments about what we did and
about what we want to do maybe you say I
know this this stupid you should do that
because in my work I really need that so
that will be useful to have this this
feedback right so okay so quickly I'm
going to define what I what I mean when
I talk about machine learning so I mean
very broadly machine learning is when a
computer learns a model from data so it
can be very stupid thing actually you
could argue that computing the mean of a
list of value is already machine
learning so so it can be simple models
for example you know fitting a curve you
have some data you want to find why
assumption of X this is this mapping
this is machine learning but it can also
be more complex for example in the case
where you want to classify image whether
there are cats or dogs you will need to
fit a model that is much bigger such as
a deep neural network in practice
actually much bigger than this this
representation and we usually classify
this machine learning three learning
types roughly when it is supervised
learning which is the most classic one
it's learning a mapping from input to
output okay as function of data trying
to predict an output that can be
catechol values numerical values or
other type of things there's also the
domain of unsupervised learning where
there's no input output it's just data
so you can see that as only inputs or
only outputs actually and and you want
to learn the structure of the data
whether it is the distribution of the
data or some to some statistical
property or just something interesting
about the data
this is domain of unsupervised learning
and a third domain that is a bit
let's known about reinforcement learning
which is really about how an agent in an
environment that has feedback from this
environment is going to learn how to
behave in this environment so you can
imagine it's for robots and and things
like that
and yes a typical task of machine
learning just to give you an idea so
image recognition sound recognition text
classification you know prediction of a
viable in data set so here you have data
set of people with aged agenda and you
try to predict the height predict the
future of a time Siri text translation
imputing missing values in the data set
in the case that just for illustration
took the problem of an image detecting
anomalies clustering data compression as
well can be done efficiently with with
machine learning as I talked about robot
learning how to move and also data
mining tasks where where so it's not a
computer you don't teach a computer to
do a specific tasks you more as the
computer to model to data and and in the
hope that it will give you insight about
this data so it's more computer to human
type of tasks so for example one way to
do it is that you I mean you look at the
model that result and they say okay
understand my data is like this is like
that and and then a human can take
decisions so that's a another task but
the techniques for at a mining and
machine learning are pretty I mean
closely related alright so as I told you
I will first talk about what we
currently have in the novel Wolfram
language and so when we talk about
machine learning function more from
language there's actually two type of
functions that the functions that allows
you to do machine learning yourself so
to do learning yourself with with your
data such as classify and predict fine
distribution dimension reduce I will
talk about about this and also some
function that we coded using machine
learning ourselves so kind of built in
machine learning or built in models that
sometimes we call it call it that way
and probably the most famous is the
image identified that you have seen at
the at the keynote yesterday probably
and so we'll talk about both of them and
then I will talk about current project
and what we what we are going to do in
the future all right so first was
classifying predict so they are the most
classic function for machine learning
there was the first function since the
version 10 and to do oh yes more the
most usual task in machine learning
which is supervised learning so learning
a mapping from input to output in Dantes
input can be very values type it can be
just data a numerical data categorical
data a mix of both image text and and
sound any mix of all that and and it
should work of course you can not really
throw anything at it but it's quite
variate the goal is that you can throw
anything at it on the other hand the
output is quite restricted it can either
be a numerical value like in the case
when you predict the hotel is someone as
function of some features so in that
case a numerical value I did reverse it
would be the function predict oh it
could be a categorical value ABC that we
call a class and and then you would use
function classify and what's important
about these functions is that we
designed them to be very high level very
automatic so that's if someone doesn't
know the machine learning algorithms of
the machine learning procedural good
practice they can still use this
function so I'm going to show quickly
about it because I want to talk about
these other functions and me people
complain that you know the talk I give
last year were the same as so give this
year so so ok for example here we are
data set so you have a list of examples
yeah with the rule on the left of the
rule you have the features I mean you
have the input and on the right of the
rule you have the output so here it's
learning to classify image pictures of
written digits to identify what it is
they are in so I ran classifier on this
list it had put a classifier function so
here the tiny dress
so it's why it's quite fast but the
performance won't be won't be great and
and then this classifier function you
can use it on some a new function so I
don't know we could use I don't know use
the eight let's see what it gives so
okay the hate is is correctly classified
you can also ask for the probabilities
on it let's ask just the top
probabilities so this says I believe you
know according to my data according to
my model that there's 64 percent of
change that it's eight twenty percent of
gender is a two and a small amount of
change that it's it's one and okay so
predict is very similar yeah again show
an image because it's it's a it's nice
to utilize and here I will associate
numerical value to this image which
actually is the area of the colored
colored part and it puts a Preta
function and this preto function I can
again use it so I don't know I can use
this one this one will tell me it's
twenty clear don't oh yeah this I guess
you cannot do by I guess your brain
level hard time actually computing the
area contrary to the thing but it
actually very accurate but this task is
a pretty easy for for predict and you
can also add the probabilities so here
since it's a continuous value it's not
probabilities but continuous
distribution so here it says that my
belief or the in the output for this
input is normal distribution centered
around 7.1 with tiny standardization so
I mean is clear that that this this
problem predict is quite precise yes
so here yes here it's always symbolic
distribution that we have in the inner
language it will yeah when we generalize
predict to any type of output it's going
to be more complicated because something
that I put a text you know what is a
distribution in the space of strings of
text it's maybe something harder so
we'll have the problem later yeah
sometimes it can give a histogram so so
yeah the distribution Instagram
there is a Bruton predictor named age
where you give your name it tells you
all you are obviously it's it's mostly
wrong but you can have the distribution
and it's belief of your age given your
and it's Instagram given your name okay
more about put here some example of
complete machine and project and as a
workshop will give with Sebastian
Ballentine Thursday about building smart
applications that learned that will use
a classifying predictor a lot okay and
enough cool documentation and all the
usual tool to learn at work that the
language has so now I will talk about a
different type of a function so it's
still learning functions except that
here the goal is not to have a function
that that is I mean the machine learning
model that is as good as possible here
it's more to have a model that is
interpret a ball that you can understand
and it can be useful for for many things
for for scientific research for example
so for example fine formula the
principle is very simple is that I have
X Y points okay and I try to find a
curve fitting these points but not not
just the curve like black box function I
want actually something with a
mathematical formula so I do find
formula and so this is a interesting
algorithm that does that that you should
actually can tell you right now you
should go to the talk of Georgia for
China Thursday at 1:00 p.m. where she
she designed his function and she will
talk a bit about what's underneath it's
some cool multicolored things going on
and in here you can plot okay so it's a
function with the data so we actually
found the function in that case they
also find distribution I won't talk
about it but it's the same but to find a
distribution so let's say you have a
Union dimensional distribution a mixture
of two things you want to to find is
there a simple symbolic distribution
that fits this data so now we'll talk
about dimensionality reduction so it's
it's not supervised learning anymore
there's no input/output the goal of
dimensionality reduction is to
so let's say let's say you have a data
set of numerical values okay a bunch of
vectors each vectors have given
dimension the goal is to map these
vectors to another vector in a lower
dimension and but but while preserving
information so it's a sort of
compression with some other properties
the idea is that in this reduced space
it would be much easier to do all sort
of tasks you want to do afterward so
there's two function one is called
dimension reduce and actually reduce
vectors and when this called dimension
reduction that produce a dimension
reducer function in the same way as
predict and classify do and that you can
use later on to reduce data so I'm going
to show quick example probably one of
its main use is for visualization so
here I have a data set and where the
input is a bunch of vectors of dimension
4 and I want to visualize these vectors
in 2d so what I do is that I apply
dimension reduce to all these vectors
and you see here that it's vectors in
dimension 2 and I can now visualize so
here it was the labels of these vectors
but this time in dimension 2
ok there's another application that I
like it's about doing data imputation so
imputing missing value over the last set
so I'm not going to detail because
there's other things I want to talk
about and but roughly I'm loading the
data set of n returned digit the same as
we we used before I'm taking the data
out of this image I'm doing a vector a
big vector of this image and I'm also
shuffling it and in the end you have a
dimension you have 10,000 vectors
dimension 784 I cut that into a training
set and the test set I create a
dimension reducer that reduce the vector
to dimension 50 ok and and what's
interesting about that is that when you
when you put a vector in this phase
space with the VC dimension
there's some sort of understanding of of
okay put that okay let's show instead
like this model is unsupervised nanny
model and and there's a sort of
understanding of a statistical structure
of the data set and that would be useful
to do image compression so here I take a
random vector you see the random vector
that I chose and I'm reducing this
vector so you see now I'll just have
fifty dimension for these these things
and if you use okay and now I'm I will
take so this vector and I will remove
some pixels I will put missing values
instead of these pixels and this is just
to visualize it and I will use it this
mention reducer with a property imputed
vectors and so the applied on the vector
that's missing values and it will
reconstruct the missing values given the
model that is as of the of the data and
I hope it's not too bad okay something
this is original image this is image
with the missing values and this is the
imputed image so so of course I mean for
image you should use the in paid
function there is Mathematica instead
but what's nice is that you can apply
that to any data set so if every data
set you train in dimension reduce and
then you'll be able to do a missing
imputation later yes so yeah I mean in
paint is not is not learned on your
trainings on your data set so yeah it
has another advantage that you have just
one image you want in paint it you just
give it to in paint it works where this
is learning an inventor so to speak with
your data
okay now let's switch to from from
function that you can use to learn to
function that we did some machine
learning to create these these functions
so the most famous is probably image
densify which I won't top merge because
again you should go to the talk of
Sebastian Bernstein it's also Thursday
after 11:00 and there's a lot of talk
Thursday you should be there sure to of
deep learning will explain in detail
what it did for imagine amplify the one
that Corey dysfunctions
and and also how you can do we will be
able to do imagine an Sofia in the
future yourself with your own data and
but to speak briefly it's something that
use a deep convolutional neural network
that we trained for a month on GPUs and
although now it's quite faster to train
and it's trained of ten ten millions of
images which is a huge amount of image
if you think about it like if you try to
think almost one years old I've seen
imagine his life you know telling that
when we measure too similar you don't
count them as the same you know because
it's correlation so if you say let's
tense each 10 second you have a new
image we should compute it you don't
have time but but it's it's probably
it's something that is not too far ok so
it's about three years of imagery it's
it's it's a lot of data and that's one
of the reason why we managed to do in
magenta fication now and I mean I can I
can okay I can resist to to show
something I will do current image does
it work okay just take a image of myself
okay good and and we can try image
identify here
alright some a person that's good and
okay little problem in the entity
representation that should be a nice
orange box but oh and one thing you can
try and I mean it's always fun to try
it's it's another thing that Sebastian
did as well it's not it's to recognize
the famous persons but sorry I don't
know how to write note a bald person
right this is English okay and yeah and
of course I'm not in this that I said so
so we just just tell me which you know
famous person is the closest to me and
oh manufacturer I guess on this image
with a chatty hug you know i boxer it's
very fast it's much more turbid okay and
so good good Sebastian II will tell you
all about that it's fascinating and okay
some other things we did about natural
numbers policing so a bunch of built-in
classifiers so you know things like a
long wage identify that it can also call
by doing classify language and certain
arguments things and okay it's English
and yeah yeah you do on current image
that's quite nice to do hmm
with an Amiga is very nice you have to
add Sebastian to do it and okay I mean
this is kind of a classic but quite
useful quad useful function something to
detect topic but restricted you know
Facebook topic actually we are planning
on we'll talk about it on doing a more
generic one and text cases that is there
is a quite recent those in 10.2 and
they're calls a natural language
processing Swiss Army knife because you
can do a lot of things with it and so
for example you can cut things into
sentence which is a tag that is not that
trivial because you have a lot of case
you know where mrs. Fox with the dots
and you might write you know you might
think that oh actually it's another
sentence oh it has been learned with
machine learning and you can ask for an
Apollo
all the noun in this sentence and Mary
okay
stolen table seems to be the noun you
can eyes okay give me all the country on
the sentence and and you can so it
doesn't just return the value you can
also ask it to return the position
things like this so you can do some cool
things for example let's say yeah I want
all the English sentence okay so okay
you know my Spanish is very limited as
well think it's good right and English
again okay so here it should extract
although English intense but I can also
ask English and give me the positions so
here it position I guess okay even me
give me the position in the string
whether English you can also have both
so I want to have the position actually
let's look at the documentation so it is
the foam string position type or type is
good so I will type position so it will
be English it will tell me in English is
there and if it's there and then I can
add other ones so let's do English and
Spanish okay you tell me as an English
sentence between these two positions
another one between the two positions
and a Spanish intense between these two
positions so that's a thing that can be
quite useful when you treat with a
visual of text and a function we did
very recently text structure which is
about visualizing the grammatical
structure of a sentence so here here you
have a path tree of the house is blue
with a part of speech here and and the
phrase type or only it and you can also
ask for an app of just part of speech
and just give you the part of speech is
to visualize but you can actually if you
look at the input form of this
it's a bunch of nested text elements and
and though you can also do computation
with it but I must say that to the
computation this case is usually end
here all right so I'm finished about
what's now in in the language and I will
talk a bit what we're more excited about
us
meaning what we're currently working on
and so one thing and by the way ya don't
need state to ask questions you know
it's also the last talk so I guess we
can take questions so I mean don't
hesitate if you have any question about
what I just talked about you don't have
to wait for the end so there's a bunch
of function that we only do that you
deep learning because we acquire
knowledge on how to train these deep
neural networks
so now we want to use that to leverage
that to train other thing that imagine
if I so want to do some specialized I
mean we are doing specialized methods if
I are currently we're working on speech
recognition there's probably a function
that will be called speech to text I
guess I hope soon on image cases as well
you can ask Sebastian about that again
which is the goal is not only to
recognize what's in the image but also
you know recognize all the element that
are in image and tell where they are
okay like in this example and then again
leverage this understanding of deep
learning to provide a framework that you
can use to train this deep neural
network and which is a big project
because because it's not tiny models
it's and owns a lot of data so usually
it uses GPU training to be faster so it
will it will allow to train the model
either on CPU or GPU and with a bit of
luck it should be in 11 us Steven II
will say for sure it will be in 11
probably ok there's also some work on
unsupervised learning
so I told about dimension radius that
was a function for unsupervised
but that's a bunch of other functions we
want to do that correspond to typical
tests that people are doing for example
cluster classify so we already have
classic clustering function in
Mathematica this one will return a
classifier function so to first do a
clustering and then output the
classifier function so if you give a new
data it will classify the data according
to these clusters and and also this
function I mean okay to be automatic so
a bit similar to create and classify
feature extracts which is something that
can have an extension to dimension
reduce except that it's not about only
in numerical data you can input anything
at it and just output a nice vector that
represents what this data is you know
compressed but prison preserving like
semantic information okay
in a way and anomaly detection imputing
missing data density estimation error
correction so I want too much about it
but it's things that we are working
right now so one thing I'm going to talk
a bit about it's I'm quite excited about
that it's a Bayesian optimization it's
actually pitch humor that is working on
that is new employee you want to talk
with image and and and that I call
sometime model-based optimization so
it's a it's when you're optimizing a
function and you in the case what this
function is very slow to evaluate so
let's say you know you are trying to
find where there is most oil in a
geographic area and then you do a drill
and you measure how much over there is
and then do another drill and you
measure and and but you have a lot of of
course it will take maybe one week to do
so you have a lot of time to think given
that I've one year of exploration where
should I do the next drill and so to do
that what you do is that you use a model
that is very good on small data so this
is not big data at all it's when you
have three four points it's tiny data
but the mallow that is very good on tiny
data and - - or you say to fit the
amount of oil
given the data you have and this feed
should have so inside of it what's your
guess about the amount of oil but also
the aerobars is very important and as
it's called Bayesian optimization
because it's very important to a
probabilistic model there and then given
this this model so here you have an
example you have two data points in a -
it's a true function in in black it's
your model and and in purple it's your
your uncertainty and from that you can
figure out okay I should probably look
there and you really you look at a place
that you think it's quite high but it's
also some uncertainty because if you
drill just next to where you drill
before you don't learn more information
even though you have a high chance to
have something high but I'm in that case
but there would be there would be a bit
useless so and then a lot of thing we're
working on is and text functions so text
cases want to drastically improve it
because there's many things missing like
if you I mean eventually text cases you
will be you should be able to ask
anything you want like give me the
street address means I don't know I mean
anything you can imagine you know I
should be able to ask Street cases so
text cases so so we are working it to
pick generic topic identification in the
same way as image on t5 we should have
to pick identify and a long way
translation that is something that we
are working on as well okay so that's
all for what we're currently working on
and now we talk about our future project
and but we're also quite excited about
but didn't started yet unfortunately one
is about extending predict to end all
any type of output because so far right
it was just pedo numerical data or
categorical data you can predict and and
won't be able to predict a vector of
categorical data a vector of calorie
goal data and numerical data together
anything sequence texts even image why
not predict an image I mean that would
be maybe bit weird it sounds weird but
it's actually a time that might that
might happen and any combination of this
output type that's something want to do
I won't work on perhaps a graphical
model which is a bit at the opposite of
our philosophy our network
philosophy but but reading classify the
philosophy this function is to be as
automatic as possible and completely
black box where was the user I don't
have to care about anything and it's
quite hard which bringing classified to
two if you have you know knowledge
yourself expert knowledge about the
problem you're doing to actually put
some some information the I mean you can
select the model with the method some
parameters but it's not the greatest the
best for that is to use graphical models
extinct that is used a lot in medicine
when they already have a lot of
expertise and you would short kind of a
long way to define a model and so you
define this model with this language and
then you have data and the parameter of
this model are unlearned and and
something that is even what you have
yeah
even more generic it's probably stick
programming which also is defining a
language that that defines probabilistic
models and something that's more generic
than graphical model what Commodore is
is a bit restricted although it's
already very useful so that's something
we are working on I mean we won't work
on and automatic data analysis so
something when you give data and a bit
like fine formula it would fit the data
in an interpretable way and and then it
would give a report about what this data
you know what what's this that analysts
found in this in this data there's some
nice example of in research group that's
motivating us to do that and won't work
ok natural core processing text
summarization topic modeling but in a
supervised way fact extraction and then
there's some other learning type such as
active learning which is when you do for
example a classifier but your data is
not annotated like you have a bunch of
cats and dogs and you have an Oracle
that can tell you which if you give it
an image it tell you ok this is the cat
and oh this is a dog and so the program
has to be smart enough to give the
Oracle the example that will make him
get as much information as possible and
it's very useful for creation tasks for
example for imagine if I you could have
the
the program that is building emergency
fire that asks the creator's what is
this image I can't recognize it so it's
actually something that ask questions
and that learns through asking these
questions
and reinforcement learning that is a
really interesting topic which is which
is a bit similar the active learning
it's it's a ok robot that needs to learn
how to walk and again it's kind of
asking a question it's a supported
environment what happens if I put my my
leg here it's better and there's always
this trade-off of a train to explore so
trying to do a movement that you have
never done before to see if it works or
not and to exploit what you already know
because you know the solution is
probably next to two to what you have
already and and finally it's something
that people ask for but it's something
that's not easy its scalability and
deployments it means that most of our I
mean algorithm only use the CPU and as a
new one network will use GPU and we want
to have all our algorithms using a GPU
and that's something that we have to do
any fault on also when you have too much
data that cannot fit into your memory it
should be able to have some kind of
online algorithm that look at the
attachment by chunk that's something we
want to work on and finally and this
might be quite hard but I think we
should have a look at that is managed to
export models to other language because
for now and you can already use in your
language through an API so you do a
classifier function operator function or
something else you deploy that to the
cloud in an API function and then you
can call this API through any program so
you can already use it in any project
but for some people that I don't know I
have a robot that is there and it cannot
be connected to internet they may want
to other program actually locally and
and because the project is not know from
language they want to convert this this
model to the language and fortunately of
course as you might expect some
problematic here because our our models
do much more than just do the prediction
they do missing imputation and they do
all kind of things that are hard to
translate one away but that's something
we're going to try to do I think